welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down
what episode 6 of season 2 has a lot to
impact from it and throughout this video
we're going to be going through it all
in it we follow a brand new character
created for the show who comes across a
Tesa and gets amazing Powers this is
probably the most unique entry in the
season and I was surprised by how much
the new character made her mock recently
there's been a big move in Hollywood to
start telling the stories of American
Natives and so far I really enjoy them
prey was fantastic and this one is too
with it's getting some stuff in Echo
coming next month I got to see the first
two episodes of that and though I can't
talk about it too much yet they do lean
in with a lot of ancient Native American
history this episode was written by Ryan
little who went above and beyond to make
it culturally authentic Gori comes from
what's known as the Mohawk people and he
consulted with language expert Cecilia
King in ordered to nail the dialogue
little also worked with historian Doug
George to ground this as close to
reality as possible well as close as it
can get with magical powers in the tesak
but you know what I mean either way from
this point on it's spoilers ahead so if
you don't want it ruined then I
recommend you turn off please hit the
thumbs up button and if you enjoy the
breakdown make sure you subscribe for
videos like this every day without the
way huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into what
what okay so the entry starts off with
us hearing the tale of Ragnarok and how
in this universe it happened centuries
prior in the 616 all like the main
Universe cuz fige says it's a 616 but
but that's like the comic Universe mate
and then 2099 says it's Earth 19999 but
I'm just going to start calling it the
movie Universe in that the tessaract was
hidden out in tburg which we saw in the
First Avenger however here C arrived
early with him he's brought doomed to
Asgard similar to how he destroyed it
during Ragnarok we see him plunging his
sword directly into the land the wild
explosion also Rifts off what happened
in that film with it wiping out the
entire plane of Ascot now during the
strike we see Odin using the tessar to
block it and can catch him in his
Warrior Gob this is something wor at the
start of Thor and they've clearly paid
attention to how he looked there this
move then sends a tesseract hurtling to
Earth in a moment that feels like it's
riffing off the start of Man of Steel
either way it lands in what would come
to be Upstate New York which is known as
the Aquis sass region sorry for
butchering that and yet going to hold my
hands up and say I'm not up as much on
the cultural aspects of this as I like
to be so if I get something wrong or
there's something I'd miss I'd love it
if you guys dropped it in the comments
to point this stuff out now kahori is
going to be a big person in the show as
well as we already know that she appears
in the finale so any stuff you leave
here that really helps it out I'll drop
that there and then take all the credit
now as always the title screen spoils
who's in it and not only do we have the
new actors but we also have kumber batch
kumber batch is cumber back and we also
get one of my favorite actors in Clancy
Brown man has returned to voice s once
again and though it's only one line I
did quite appreciate it we then cut to a
cornfield to see what's one of the
Staples of Native American food however
beyond that the Deno AIO symbolically
held of corn as a symbol of sustenance
and life according to utah.edu this was
one of the four sacred plants that was
said to be given to the Denny as corn
provided both food and Medicine the S
also says that eating corn brought
clearer thoughts and it also unlocked
new knowledge the idea of new knowledge
is represented in kahori who discovers a
tesseract and it takes her somewhere
else as she runs through the forest
alongside wat who stumbles across the
grounds of an old Battlefield and not to
get all pet cemetery on your map but but
right Native American burial grounds are
obviously used in horror a lot duud the
Superstition around them the Overlook in
The Shining was said to be built on one
there was poter I and of course the
aforementioned pet cemetery which is
somewhere I don't want to be buried now
I know it's a stereotype but these
stories have basis and because the
skeletons here were never properly
buried the land said to be cursed again
try not to be ignorant but I I am an
idiot how cahor talks about the leg
there and how the people fought to gain
control of it this is because the legend
says it has the power to transport those
to the sky world and the Tesseract of
course also houses the space Stone this
allows one to travel to any point in
space which is why Thanos was able to do
it the Tesseract itself actually has
poers link with black holes which is why
the portals also appear like that black
holes are also the key to traveling in
the Multiverse which is why they were
brought up so much during Loki MD's done
a big video talking about them all which
I definitely recommend that you check
out there's lots of stuff apparently
going to be involving them in the future
so that's definitely the perfect video
to brush up on them and you should
probably go there instead of staying
here either way Upon returning home they
see it's being ransacked by colonizers
who chase the pair until I find the lake
turns out the one above was a decoy and
the real treasure Lies Beneath the
surface kahori shot and then sent into
it which is when the tesak draws her in
rivers are often seen in Legends as
being mystical which is why they get
used in stories a lot the one ring was
discovered in one Excalibur was tossed
into one too and beyond that they can
also be a place of rebirth this is why
baptisms were carried out in them two as
they washed away the sins so that one
could start a new but I'm not a rapper
here kahori sucked into the tessar
before being shut out du the space
Stone's ability to send its use away a
blue portal also opens up in the sky
similar to what we saw during The
Avengers kahori then arrives in the sky
world where she comes across those that
were sent there too it's likely that
when s Struck it it cracked the cube and
since then it's Led Out waves of space
St magic in the comics The Cosmic Cube
was a weapon used by The Red Skull that
when fractured started to change reality
though they changed it for the movie in
order to house an infinity stone I
wonder if they looked it that for some
of the inspiration we of course also
have Captain Marvel who shot the thing
in order to get powers and this like
Gori washed her in its glow the skill
set is slightly different though but you
can see how it washing you can give you
certain abilities now we learn that
kori's ancestors travel there and can
even see images of them in the
constellations constellations have often
been used to tell stories with ancient
civilizations using them for the basis
of their myths we learn that people
disappeared when going to the lake and
it was deemed curs to stop people from
returning
however these people they simply moved
in the civilizations being imbued with
space Stone magic which we see them
performing in Infinity War when Loi end
to stab Thanos you can see held back the
knife by using space Stone magic this is
why we can see the blue on the blade as
it shows that's what's controlling Loki
now this is why they're able to fish the
river and we get given The Grand Tour by
a character named Atarax these people
haven't been able to tell those back
home because they haven't been able to
get back but I to be fair I wouldn't
want to go back and tell them either
give it all to me the land is a paradise
and they don't age you get sick plus you
know this is a guy that always hits the
thumbs up this also explains how kahori
was able to survive the gunshot and heal
up as quickly as she did however kahori
worries about life back home and we see
that the village isn't doing too well
attacked by kisto Gonzalo we then see as
the village Burns around them he also
mentions Queen Isabella of Spain who
pops up later on which status is rough
the end of the 1400s or potentially the
start of the 1500s hearing of the
Fountain of Youth this is what they're
here to get now back with Gori tarx asks
what kind of clay she's made from when
we see her mastering her abilities there
were some that believe the first humans
were made from this which came from the
story of POV he also mentions how he's
got some turtle within him and there
were lots of Native American myths that
were based around these animals goori
says that she has some wolf in her which
makes me think this might be playing off
the coyote and the Turtle this is
similar to our rabbit and the turtle
race which is why a tarax is slower than
she is he just wants her to stay behind
whereas kahori is desperate to get home
many have tried but none have made it
out and those who lived here have
settled and made the most of it they
continue their rituals though and Carry
Out hunts in which they grab the fruit
of the back of the planet's native
animals she ends up flipping one over
her head which I wondered if it was
ripping off Peggy doing it with the car
obviously she's the bloody best and back
on Earth we see as a soldiers treading
to the W
taken to the paradise we see as kahor is
finally happy and even get a moment
riffing off Titanic however the piece is
broken up by the arrival of the troops
and I I was wondering why they didn't
have the powers but maybe they just
didn't know how to use them yet kind of
explained it to myself there the ending
explain guy is giving himself his own
ending explain now we see she bites the
others for losing their way due to
living in Paradise as she sees it as
neglecting the People Back Home pulling
the portal down she decides to return
there with the others question
questioning whether they should leave
the peace they found back on Earth we
catch the Native Americans getting sent
towards the ship where it is most likely
that they would be enslaved now not to
stick up for Isabella mate I'm not
trying to be a white knight for her but
according to the history box she was
actually against Native Americans being
used as them she actually ordered the
return and arrest of Christopher
Columbus because of his position on it
however the people were forced to be
classed as subjects of her which again
was against their will this meant she
could claim whatever she wanted and
ravaged the land for her own benefit
again mate if you feel I'm wrong on this
stuff just drop it below and I'll try to
not let my fragile little ego get to
offended now kahori storms the beach and
shows off her new abilities but the
cannonballs prove to be more than the
bullets the sky people arrive inspired
by her speech and decide to help out
against the Invaders the people are
saved and though kahori could have lived
in the peaceful lands she decided to
return home and take the fight to them
cut across to Spain where we catch the
queen being told her forces have failed
to conquer the new world world at this
point Gori and K step out the portal
like Thanos in Infinity war and tell her
that they just want peace the throne is
destroyed as an example there's going to
be no more war and in the end it's all
coming up milous but now but then
Supreme strange he shows up and ruins it
all and says that he's been looking for
kahori what happens next we don't know
yet but it's likely going to take us in
that finale I'm guessing that the Peggy
stuff's going to play off there too and
I am interested to see where it's going
to go now tomorrow Mt is going to be
doing the video cuz I just haven't got
the time to cover it because of
Christmas don't worry yet man's going to
smash it and what what what you mean his
videos are better than mine you you what
you what anyway I hope to see you back
then and I'll be back for episode 8
please drop a like on the video and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoilers side Squad then
please click the join button you get
early access to videos every week and it
goes such a long way to helping us out
we going to get some heavy spoilers
merch we've also got our t-shirt line
located below the video that will let
you pick up all kinds of tops like our
Theory time one house of dragon stuff
Marvel te's and a lot more we drop new
designs on there all the time too so
definitely keep an eye out for them and
thank you for all your support now if
you want something else to watch you got
yesterday's video on screen right now so
definitely head over there right after
this by the way huge thank you for sting
through the video I've been Paul I see
you next time take care
[Music]
peace